aquí tenemos un triángulo rectángulo es
un triángulo rectángulo puedes ver que
tiene un ángulo recto en la esquina y
por eso por eso es llamado triángulo
rectángulo ahora el lado más largo de
este triángulo llamamos la hipotenusa
ese lado puedes verla como lado más
largo o como el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 90 grados entonces esa es la
hipotenusa es una palabra bastante
elegante para una idea tan sencilla
bueno al menos así yo lo considero ese
es el lado más largo del triángulo
rectángulo o el lado opuesto al ángulo
recto si tú escuchas la palabra
hipotenusa si tú dices o perfecto
perfecto bueno simplemente están
hablando de del lado de ese lado del
triángulo rectángulo ahora bien lo que
yo quiero hacer en este vídeo es probar
la relación de hecho es una relación
bastante famosa que hay entre las
longitudes de los lados de un triángulo
rectángulo entonces digamos que este
segmento hace tiene longitud a digamos
que el segmento b se tiene longitud d
finalmente que la hipotenusa la longitud
del segmento ave tiene longitud ce
entonces este éste tiene longitud c
ahora veamos si podemos llegar a una
relación entre ave y 6 para hacer esto
primero voy a construir una línea un
segmento mejor dicho entonces construyó
un segmento entre 6 la hipotenusa y la
construyó de tal manera que se
intersectan de manera perpendicular
forma un ángulo recto y llamamos a ese
punto d entonces bueno esto siempre se
puede hacer como simplemente tú imagina
imaginar rotar este triángulo ajá solo
para que te des una idea de cómo siempre
puedes construir un punto así entonces
ya lo rotem está la hipotenusa abajo
este punto este punto es el punto b este
punto es a y bueno simplemente lo rote
este punto es el punto ce imagina tirar
una roca con un hilo desde desde el
punto se va a caer de manera
perpendicular sobre la hipotenusa y eso
fue básicamente lo que hicimos para
establecer ade en el segmento ave y la
razón por la que yo hice eso es porque
ahora puedo hacer varias relaciones
entre tres triángulos entre semejanza de
triángulos porque tenemos tres
triángulos del triángulo a desde el
triángulo de bc y el triángulo grande el
original y vamos a establecer similitud
entre estos tres triángulos y primero te
voy a mostrar que el triángulo ha de ser
el triángulo adc es similar al triángulo
grande porque ambos tienen un ángulo
recto el triángulo adese tiene este
ángulo recto y estos ángulos claramente
son suplementarios porque suman 180 dos
ángulos rectos suman 180 así que ambos
tienen un ángulo recto el triángulo
pequeño tiene un ángulo recto el
triángulo original bueno claramente es
un triángulo rectángulo así que bueno
por en decir un ángulo recto y también
ambos comparten este ángulo en el
vértice a entonces el ángulo de hace o
el ángulo b hace como lo quieras ver es
el ángulo que comparten así que podemos
escribir que el triángulo bueno voy a
iniciar con el más pequeño este
triángulo
puse con sombra verde entonces ok
el triángulo adc voy a escribir esto
aquí el triángulo abc es similar al
triángulo voy a iniciar con el con orden
de de de ángulos entonces el triángulo
el triángulo a lo voy a este ángulo el
triángulo acb
acp y como son similares podemos
establecer una relación entre las
razones de sus lados por ejemplo sabemos
que la razón entre las dos
correspondientes bueno de hecho
de hecho en general para similitud de
triángulos sabemos que la razón entre
las dos correspondientes será una
constante entonces podemos tomar la
razón de la hipotenusa de este triángulo
el menor la hipotenusa es hace entonces
tenemos hace sobre la hipotenusa del
triángulo grande la cuál sabe hace sobre
ave esto es igual a hace a des uno de
los lados ajá estoy tomando segmentos
similares de ambos triángulos y
tendríamos entonces hace sobre ave es
igual a ade sobre hace observar los
triángulos y tratar de estudias o genial
ade está en el en el en el ángulo azul y
el ángulo recto entonces el lado hace
está entre el ángulo azul y el ángulo
recto pero del triángulo mayor
y si es confuso esto para ti simplemente
observa la similitud y bueno ahí vas a
encontrar segmentos correspondientes a
se corresponde a ave en el triángulo
grande y adem en el triángulo pequeño
corresponde a hace en el triángulo
grande es lo que está pasando a se
corresponde a ve a de corresponde a
hacer ya lo tenemos esa igualdad
entonces bueno vamos a seguir sabemos
que hace corresponde a minúscula a se
corresponde a minúscula acá tenemos otro
hace esto es a y no tenemos etiqueta
para el segmento a de tampoco para ave
'nos y de hecho para ver si tenemos ave
es igual a c tiene longitud c entonces
pero pero no tenemos para a de así que
bueno hay que hay que etiquetarlo
llamémosle al segmento a de con de
minúscula esto es a de y todo esto todo
esto es que entonces también para el
segmento de bella memos lea ese segmento
y eso facilita las cosas entonces
tenemos que sobresee es igual a d sobre
a y si multiplicamos cruzado
tenemos que apurar lo cual es al
cuadrado es igual a ceder y es un
resultado bastante interesante ahora
vamos a ver
veamos qué podemos hacer con el otro
triángulo con este triángulo podemos ver
que tiene un ángulo recto cierto
entonces tiene un ángulo recto y el
triángulo grande también tiene un ángulo
recto ahora ambos comparten este ángulo
entonces por similitud de ángulo ángulo
los triángulos serán similares y podemos
decir que los triángulos los triángulos
b deseen este triángulo obedece uso el
orden de los ángulos entonces el
triángulo bdc es similar al triángulo
veces a de del ángulo rosa puig del
ángulo rosa al ángulo recto y después
voy al ángulo en el vértice am y ya con
esto lo que sigue lo que sigue es
relacionarlos podemos decir que la razón
la razón en el triángulo menor aquí
empecé el segmento veces sobre el
segmento vean estoy tomando simplemente
soy tomando las
hipotenusa que corresponden a cada cada
triángulo entonces veces sobre b
y aquí voy a tomar otro color veces
sobre vean es igual al segmento b d
sobre el segmento bc entonces verde
sobre el segmento bc simplemente tomó
los vértices correspondientes y aquí ya
tengo que veces veces ve desees ve ve a
ese entonces ve a ese y bebe es y ahora
lo que lo que sigue es multiplicar
cruzado como lo hicimos anteriormente y
nos quedaría entonces que ve por ver es
ve al cuadrado
esto será igual como lo hicimos si es lo
mismo lo mismo entonces ve al cuadrado
es igual a c
esto es igual a c
y ahora sigo lo interesante porque
podemos sumar estos dos podemos sumar lo
voy a escribir acá abajo para que quede
más claro entonces tenemos que ve al
cuadrado más x
si sumamos tenemos tenemos al cuadrado
más de al cuadrado más b al cuadrado
esto es igual hace por de c por de más
se pone simplemente estoy sumando estoy
sumando normal y tenemos una c en ambos
términos de del lado derecho así que
vamos a factorizar lo esto será igual
hace por de más y de más
pero que esté más que es de más de esta
longitud y en esta longitud entonces
demás
es igual a c así que esto es cm y se
porte es igual hace al cuadrado esto es
igual a sea al cuadrado y tenemos
tenemos al cuadrado más b al cuadrado es
igual hace al cuadrado eso te parece te
parece
algo familiar no tenemos al cuadrado
voy a escribirlo bien acabamos de
establecer establecer que que al
cuadrado más b al cuadrado es igual a c
al cuadrado y lo cual aplica para bueno
de hecho aplicó para un triángulo
arbitrario entonces acabamos de
establecer que la suma de los cuadrados
de cada uno de los lados es igual al
cuadrado de la hipotenusa lo cual es uno
de los de los teoremas más famosos que
hay en matemáticas nombrado por
pitágoras esto fue por pitágoras no sé
no sé si él fue el primero en llegar a
esto pero pero si es una base si es un
pilar fundamental para la geometría y
para la trigonometría de hecho si sabes
si conoces dos de los lados de un
triángulo puede podrás saber cuánto mide
el otro lado gracias a este gran teorema
a muchísimo teorema de pitágoras